joining us now Texas Senator Ted Cruz
Senator how are you uh by the way I'm
watching your race closely that Playbook
is being played down in your state of
Texas here you have been at the border
again and again and again you gave this
program exclusive images early on when
uh in the middle of covid when they
wouldn't allow our cameras inside these
facilities that had kids and cages
overcrowded in the middle of a pandemic
and if it wasn't for you we wouldn't
have had those photos uh and yet they're
trying to bludgeon you and lie about
your record in Texas
already well look Chuck Schumer and the
Democrats have painted a bullseye on
Texas they're coming after me Schumer
has made clear I'm his number one Target
in the country he's going to spend over
a hundred million do trying to beat me
and and so I want to encourage your
viewers go to tedcruz.org tedcruz.org
tedcruz.org I I need your help they're
coming after me I got to say what is
happening in Texas what is happening on
the border it is a crisis at a level we
have never seen before as you noted I I
spend a lot of time on the southern
border I go out on midnight Patrol with
the border of Patrol agents I went into
the Biden cages when they wouldn't allow
Fox News in they wouldn't allow
reporters in their argument by the way
when they wouldn't allow the reporters
in and the TV cameras in they said the
TV cameramen might have covid and so as
you know I pulled out my phone and
filmed the conditions the deplorable POS
conditions they tried to stop you
Senator yes they did they tried stop you
a US senator they didn't want the truth
to come out that they did not want you
cannot see what's happening there and
defend it last year 853 migrants died
Crossing illegally into this country you
cannot see the children as I've seen
many times who've been horribly abused
physically and sexually by human
traffickers you can't see the women
who've been violently sexually assaulted
by human traffickers you cannot defend
it Biden's entire strategy is hope the
media ignores it and and by the way in
an exercise of kah he stood up last week
and said well the problem is the
Republicans won't fund border security
what an utter lie Joe Biden and KLA
Harris and Alejandra mayorcas are
letting illegal immigrants into this
country they've created this problem and
I'll tell you Sean there's an amazing
phenomenon whatever the Democrats in the
leftwing accuse the other side of doing
it is what they're doing you just showed
Joe Biden giving a speech saying we must
defend democracy mind you at the exact
same time that Democrats in Colorado in
Maine are trying to prevent the voters
from voting for Donald Trump the most
anti-democratic step we've seen in our
lifetimes all right so and and the
amazing thing is morcus actually in the
last week has blamed climate change
blamed Greg Abbott your Governor blamed
you uh blamed Donald Trump for what's
happening at the border and now they're
claiming well Congress hasn't done their
job we need comprehensive immigration
reform we didn't have this problem when
Donald Trump was President we had the
state of Mexico policies the walls were
being built hundreds of miles of them
and they would it all would have been
completed by now the Border would have
been secure none of this would have
happened what is their motivation is
their motivation to say oh we're the
party we're going to help you break the
law every if you or I did this we go to
jail uh we'll help you break the law
we'll set you up in another state we'll
give you free train Transportation maybe
one day we'll give you citizenship and
we hope you remember us when you go vote
is that their plan so I think that's a
big part of it I think there are really
three motivations at play with the
Democrats number one on every policy
issue they've handed the agenda over to
the radical left so on Law and Order
they've handed the agenda over to the
radical abolish the police nuts in the
Democrat Party on Israel they've handed
the agenda over to the radical pramas
nuts in their party the anti-semites in
their party on on issues of gender
they've handed the agenda over to the
radical surgically mutilate the children
Extremes in their party and On the
Border they've handed the agenda over to
the extreme left that believes borders
are immoral we should have no border
anyone should be able to come into this
country that's who's setting the Biden
Administration agenda number two the
corporate media is utterly corrupt so
they don't report on it if you watch Fox
News as you and I both do you know about
what's happening on the border but if
you watch CNN there is no border crisis
ABC CBS NBC nothing to see here and
number three it's what you just said I
think a lot of Democrats know there's
massive human suffering but they're
willing to overlook that human suffering
because they want to stay in power and
they look at the 9.6 million illegal
immigrants and they think every one of
them is a future Democrat voter and we
get to stay in power if we change the
electorate and just allow open borders
and I got to say Sean the most dangerous
thing I believe the odds are
extraordinary high that in the year
2024 we will see a major terrorist
attack in the United States they Hamas
and hezb terrorists coming across our
Southern border right now and Joe Biden
and the Democrats in the House and
Senate they do not care well we know
that the possibility I say it's 100% we
know that we've had hundreds from Iran
show up at our Southern door border if
you're from Iran Syria hundreds more
from there uh what are you doing at our
Southern border
from Egypt the home of the Muslim
Brotherhood uh 6,000 plus from
Afghanistan Al-Qaeda uh we got over
12,000 from Russia 26,000 from China now
let me be very clear because Democrats
say they're racist they don't want
people of color coming into the country
that's I don't care where people come
but I'd like people vetted I'd like to
know they don't have radical
associations I'd like to know that
they're healthy especially in a pandemic
world post-pandemic world we're living
in and I'd like to know they're not
going to be a financial Bur on the
American people do it legally and then
welcome to our country I don't really
give a damn where you come from yeah
look that's exactly right let me give
you some stats on the terror watch list
in fiscal year
2017 two people were encountered on the
border on the terror watch list in 2018
6 in 2019 0er in 2020 two in fiscal year
2021 most of which Trump was President
15 what happed happened the next year
fiscal year
98 what happened the next year fiscal
year 23
172 we went from zero and two to
172 and those are the ones we know about
that doesn't count the 2 million Goda
aways last year that that that pose a
dramatic threat this Administration is
endangering the safety of every American
because they do not know what terrorists
are coming into this border and they're
willing to say we want to stay in power
more than we want to keep your family
safe if they allowed terrorists in and
we're right and I don't think we're
wrong I pray to God we're wrong but I
don't think we're going to be proven
wrong if there I want to be wrong if
there are Terror cells as we believe
there are and it h I think there has to
be the sheer numbers mathematically it
is just statistically right there if you
Commander why wouldn't you send someone
in I mean it's scream for it they will
have blood on their hands cuz they have
allowed this to happen all right Senator
thank you and by the way they are
targeting Senator Cruz big time we'll be
following that closely hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else